this like incentive structure is a big
part of why we're seeing such incredible
polarization even the really respectable
papers are leaning more and more into
like clickbaity rage baity tactics in
order to maintain their their market
share on average the average person just
doesn't know where to go to get reliable
information anymore people don't tune
into the news to find out what the facts
are they find out to get the emotional
hit it just feels like there's this this
Force like a ra blade coming up through
the fabric of reality of like shared
reality that is trying to like bipoc
everything what's this m concept that
you've come up with to describe where
our media and New Media ecosystem is
going wrong um well I didn't come up
with the m concept it actually comes
from an old um originally it comes from
this old Bible story about this uh
horrible cult that was so obsessed with
winning wars they were willing to
sacrifice more and more of the things
they cared about um up to and including
their children who they would sacrifice
in a bonfire in this like burning Effigy
Of This demon god thing called mik in
the belief that it would then reward
them with um you know all the military
power they could want and so this sort
of story became kind of like synonymous
with this idea of sacrificing too much
in the name of winning
and like the the the force of of when
competition goes wrong essentially and
then in I think 2014 Scott Alexander of
slate star codex or now astral codex 10
um wrote this amazing blog post called
meditations on mik where he's like he
basically draw connects the dots between
all of these like mentions of mollock
throughout history and put it into in
into like modern Game Theory terms
because he noticed he's like it seems
like there's this like
mechanism
where the the same sort of mechanism
that is driving a lot of different
problems in the world you know whether
it's like tragedy of the commons type
problems where
um companies will take you know
shortcuts to get you know to to St keep
their share of the market or whatever
you know like um use cheap plastic P
packaging or something like that because
that's the most cost cost efficient
thing they can do but then it's like
creating all these negative
externalities um you know for the future
uh or or deforestation all of these sort
of tragedy of the commons type
situations are created by these like
misaligned game theoretic incentives um
and as well as things like arms races
you know the fact that we ended up with
60,000 nuclear weapons on Earth far more
than we would ever need to like maintain
mutually assur destruction is again
because it's like the the the game
theory dictates it if your opponent does
you know builds up a stronger Arsenal
now you've got to do it and now they've
got to do it and so on so it's like
it's these like screwed up short-term
incentives that each individual person
is technically rational for following
but if everyone does them creates these
like bad outcomes for the world that's
kind of what this mik thing is um and
that's what it sort of become synonymous
with and I was you know and I'm sure
like you guys just generally apped at
the direction that the media has been
taking over the last few years I mean I
mean
it's if it bleeds it leads has been a
strategy they've been using since
whenever right but it it feels like
since the internet and certainly since
social media that the the competition
dial has been turned up and it it feels
like even the really respectable papers
are leaning more and more into like
click baity rage baity tactics in order
to maintain their their market share
essentially and so it's the same kind of
mechanism like you know you're an editor
and you notice that your uh user you
know your readership numbers are like
waning compared to your competitors and
you notice all your competitors are now
doing like more like slightly more
clickbaity stuff well now you kind of
have to do it too right um because if
you don't you're going to get left
behind them and this is again the same
moock mechanism so yeah I made like a
whole little short film about it it's
very good I've really enjoyed watching
it and the interesting thing to me is
that for a while there was the narrative
well mainstream media is dying corrupt
blah blah blah blah blah which is true
mhm the New Media is the answer and I
think there's an element of that that
can potentially be true but New Media
also is subject to various algorithms
and various incentives that clearly in I
mean I look at some very popular
YouTubers who comment in our space on
stuff the just the titles and thumbnails
and I'm like if I just ingested that for
a week I don't think I'd be a very happy
emotionally stable person right you know
they are doing you know and every now
and again we'll have a thumbnail that
says something along those lines but I'm
just saying it's it seems to me like
while the New Media potentially offers a
solution it is subject to many of the
same flaws and perverse incentives yeah
it's just a big old attention game right
everyone is trying to compete for each
other other's attention whether it's um
big media companies whether it's
individual influencers people um even
like government orgs you know NOS there
everyone is trying to get their voice
heard and so it incentivizes people to
do whatever tactics are best at doing
that
and it seems like the best emotions for
going viral I mean they're certainly not
like coolheadedness or Nuance right it's
it's fear rage um and then the
occasional like really like sort of
exciting happy story but rage in
particular even more than fear is a is
um
uh like a sort of action triggering uh
emotion and because the uh business
models not only of you know influencers
but also mainstream media now is more
like how can you maximize Impressions
how you want an active emotion that
encourages people to go out and like
share and comment and that's why rage is
just so useful and the most effective
way of triggering rage is like getting
people well you know whipped up into
tribal frenzy and so it's this I think
you know this this like incentive
structure is a big part of why we're
seeing such incredible
polarization um you know it's hard to
say where did the polarization start
it's been there was this really cool um
gr like uh like chart that was posted um
I'll try and send it to you guys uh that
showed how it looked like I called it
the mitosis of Congress I don't know if
you saw it it's like but you send it to
us we'll put it in yeah it's like
Democrats and Republicans over the years
like how much sort of overlap there was
in like opinion and you know was in
Aggregate and just over time it's become
more and more and more polarized until
the point now it's like there's
basically no overlap ever and what's
interesting though is that this this
process started before the internet so I
don't think the internet is the cause
but it's basically just turned up the
acceleration because it's you know the
tales were already coming apart it's
just that
um yeah it's like it's turned up the
competition dial everyone's leaning into
it harder and harder it's really
interesting that you say that because if
I think back to our country of the UK
and we're talking about generating rage
I mean who did that better than the
Tabloid press in the 80s and the90s I
mean there were masters of it there's a
Netflix series out about David Beckham
and David Beckham during the World Cup
he got sent off for basically a little
kick out at an Argentine player who then
made a meal out of it and then he became
a National hate figure the The Daily
Mirror put a dart board with his face on
it and they generated this campaign
against him where he became the most
hated man in the UK so it's it's been
going on for a long time I just what I
find interesting is how in a way these
mainstream media Outlets are doing this
even more because they realize they're
becoming less and less relevant yeah I I
completely agree they I
mean it that that's the thing I'm angry
at them for doing it you know when it
particularly like the BBC right and to
be fair I think they have held on
perhaps the longest out of all the
outlets
but you know there certain things
particularly like I see them make
articles around the tech space or
something like that areas that I know
and I'm like okay it's very clear that
you have a particular political slot
usually they they lean left not always
but um that interview between Elon Musk
and the BBC journalist where the BBC
journalist ran out of questions like I'm
like we we we will spend the next year
working incredibly hard to get Elon on
the show and we would like be desperate
for every extra minute of time and this
guy just wanted to attack him and then
he ran out of attack questions like okay
I'm bored now it was unbelievable you've
got one of the most relevant men on the
planet and you run out of things to say
yeah yeah it's not ideal no well more
more generally like
yeah it it just feels like there's this
this
Force like a razor blade coming up
through the fabric of reality of like
shared reality that is trying to like
bif foca everything that's what this
again I keep calling it mik you know
it's helpful to almost think of it as a
kind of agentic entity what does that
mean sorry like something I'm not saying
actually there is a force that wants us
to fight mhm but it's almost helpful to
think of it as there is this like de
that is like want it just it its
lifeblood is people being at War and
people arguing and people fighting and
the world doing badly because we aren't
able to coordinate and that's the sort
of outcome of this because like
we're the type of problems the
civilization is moving into you know I
have a background in philanthropy and
like a you know Global catastrophic risk
I've sort of work in like semi in
research in that but certainly in like
communicating about it
and almost all these problems whether
it's you know
future pandemics and there will be worst
ones in covid um a or climate change or
any of these big really big problems
they're all a result of us not being
able to really coordinate effectively if
we could coordinate well then they would
be relatively trivial like we've known
roughly what we need to do to mitigate
climate change you know or at least
temper it but we haven't been able to
get our act together to do it because
there's so many incentives for everyone
to defect each time it's like well okay
M you know you're a poor country who's
trying to get grow their GDP and they've
got a bunch of coal of course like they
what are they meant to do like you know
this is the fastest ways to lift our
people out of poverty but technically
they are defecting from like the global
Optimum which is no one uses coal right
and like uses perhaps a slightly more
expensive but clean of source of energy
um and so the the problem with this like
media issue in particular the fact that
like the media are becoming increasingly
polarized everything is more optimized
towards like rage and like volatility
and and and and hype unnecessarily like
Hyperbole and that kind of stuff is that
now you know okay yes you'll get like
little Echo Chambers where people really
really trust their particular news
source but on average the average person
just doesn't know where to go to get
reliable information anymore it's really
really hard and if we can't like
collectively make sense of these
difficult problems how the [__] are we
going to then like communicate and
coordinate on actual reasonable
Solutions which is one of the reasons
why like you know I think Co was always
going to be too um it was so
transmissible that was the cat was out
the bag really as soon as that you know
it took him too long to took governments
too long to realize they needed to do
something and and then in the end they
ended up going crazy um you know they
acted too slowly in the beginning and
then they lingered with stupid solutions
for too long um but if we can't have a
shared understanding of reality and we
have a media system which is meant to
like the purpose of the media is to you
know in an Ideal World inform people
about the the nature of reality so that
you can get like a healthy Parallax of
views and come to like sane conclusions
kind of as a hive mind if the media are
doing the exact opposite of that like
making people whipped up into frenzies
and splitting them apart then we can't
coordinate on these problems so well you
make really good points there I mean one
of the things you said there that I
think probably isn't true though is I
don't think the function of the media at
least one in terms of observable
behavior is to inform people I think
politics
culture and everything to do with those
things has now become entertainment the
media is entertainment the news is
entertainment uh people don't tune into
the news to find out what the facts are
they find out to get the emotional hit
right it's like a dopamine Source yes
you know and the tribal rage that comes
with it obviously is a very powerful s
you know it's a drug um but I'm I'm
curious to to talk about this concept of
shared reality because I suppose we've
got to a point where wherever you think
I mean there's you know this is why the
trans debate has become so prominent
because you're just going it's two
groups of people who can't even agree on
on something as as basic as biology
right and so I mean how do we have a
shared reality if there are people who
who who can't Define what a woman is and
there's other people who think it's the
do you see what what I'm saying right I
mean I don't know I think with with with
issues like that like almost every
cultur war
issue is the reason why it's so front
and center even though in theory it
shouldn't be you know like there's far
bigger issues in the world about like
you know trying to Define what is or
what isn't a woman like it's um not to
some
people the feminists would would
disagree with you but let me the thing
is I agree with you that in terms of the
issue itself it's insignificant compared
to the problems we Face however I would
argue if you have a disagreement about
the very concept of Truth at that basic
level that is like whoo yeah no and and
and you're right it it points to and
this and this is the thing so whether
it's trans stuff whether it's um the
debate over capitalism all of these
different like cultur War Hot Topics
that I think the reason why they are so
of successful in meme space again if
each like War topic isn't its own like
entity is because there are genuinely
like valid perspectives from both sides
and like any that which is going to
create tension like where because the
system like because the media the way
the their incentive structures are set
up they are opt you know they are being
funneled into focusing on whatever topic
will get the most clicks and Views and
th thus anything that has the maximum
amount of tension because there are
conflicting arguments and viewpoints
they are like messy things like you know
yes I am someone who believes strongly
in in you know I think biology is the
closest thing you know it's one of our
solid paths to reality at the same time
I very fundamentally believe that people
should be free to live and and choose
how they express themselves as long as
they don't hurt other people as long as
they don't yeah sure but like I so these
are two fundamental things but they are
like you know that that creates tension
you know there will be certain things
where some someone's Choice back like
butts up against the rights of someone
else's and it's like what do we do in
these and
I I think in part why these issues have
taken off so much is because let's think
like you know like the the trans issue
thing it
became because it's not like it's a New
Concept right the concepts of trans
people have been around for at least you
know there's been like writings of it
for like certainly the last century but
it's like the media latched onto it
because it was like it the media machine
this entity that wants to just like keep
the the wheels churning and maximize
profit noticed oh this is a thing this
is a potential trigger point let's lean
into this and then it became more and
more inflamed than it needed to be um is
that so I'm really curious to explore
this with you so this why I'm pushing
back um we are kind of in the media and
we talk about that issue quite a lot now
I can tell you from a personal
perspective why I am interested in it
I'm interested in it because I think
truth matters and what we are trying to
optimize for here is the truth so when
someone says you know Abracadabra Stacy
I'm now a different person I respect
your right to call yourself whatever the
hell you want but as you say it butts up
against the rights of other people and
also there are truth claims being made
right in that discussion and I'm like if
we can't even agree about Truth at this
basic level how are we going to solve
any problem so to me I I understand your
perspective and I bet you there's lots
of media Outlets that have focused in on
it because they're like this is why you
get the clicks but for me it's like
while you know some children are being
hurt by this process and while we can't
agree on Truth we have to get somewhere
on this issue we have to find a way to
resolve those tensions which you're
right exist but truth matters
right the thing that I would want to
talk about when we're talking about the
media is personal responsibility and
look you can argue that these
corporations these organizations are
evil you know they're manipulating us
and that very well may that may very
well be true but there's also a part of
it is you have agency and you are
allowing yourself to be manipulated no
it's a very good point um the this guy I
Patrick Ryan came up with this term
psycho
security and he he's been saying like
the biggest issue of this decade in his
opin I'm not sure if I would completely
agree but that we all need to be
thinking about and working on is this
idea of Psy psycho security same as
you'd have cyber security for your
computer or physical security for your
house or whatever we need psycho
security to protect ourselves from the
increasingly powerful manipulation tools
that are flying about on the internet MH
and whether these tools are being used
because someone is evil or whether these
tools are being used because they're
simply stuck in a like um you know a
for-profit incentive game that makes you
you know they're funneling they're
trying to just maximize their profits so
it's like more the game that's evil it
it doesn't really matter the point is
we're spending more and more time on
these devices and these devices have not
really been built for all like mental
health they've been built for again kind
of either you know maximizing profits or
maximizing you know just getting people
to stay on them for as long as possible
and so how do we build these
psychological defenses against these
various things um whether it's like Tik
Tok trying to just turn you into [__]
droing uh [__] just scrolling a thing
or the media trying to turn you into a
like foaming at the mouth politically
polarized rabid person it's it's how do
we build up these sort of psychological
defenses without going full arish and
going like okay no more phone for me it
might be that's right and the thing is
is that AI is going to make this more
like speed all this up because you know
AI is like it's such a broadly useful
technology if you can hack intelligence
itself then anything that anything that
there's an incentive to use in
intelligence for it will get used for
and that includes all the really good
stuff solving all these big problems but
also speeding up the existing problems
we have like I it' be terrifying to
think you know if like all the really
partisan news news outlets suddenly got
AI you know really personalized AIS for
each individual user to get them to keep
getting even more and more Angry that's
the way things are trending wow yeah
like that every company on Earth is
waking up to the fact that AI is like
there's going to be an AI tool to speed
up their company and that means all the
good ones but also all the like bad ones
and and even the criminal ones criminal
Enterprises will soon have access to AI
for whatever crappy thing is they want
to do casinos wanting to addict people
to slot machines like I mean that those
are already sort of dopamine hijacking
off but that kind of thing I mean
arguably that's what social media is
it's our first like interaction uh on a
broad scale with like rudimentary AI
because it's you know they might have
started out really basic algorithms but
these things are getting more and more
intelligent more and more personalized
like my Twitter feed damn that [__]
knows exactly same with my Instagram as
well my Instagram is like my uh Twitter
is what makes me all like fired up and
like intellectually interested in
something and Instagram is all the
things that just like when I just want
to chill out and like you know I want to
be entertained on the toilet it's just
here's funny here's funny animal doing
that here's silly thing there um they're
so tailored to my brain because I've
been freely giving them my information
all this time and it's AI is just as AI
gets better this is going to get
stronger and stronger and stronger and
that does not sound like a good thing
doesn't seem like it no we'll get back
to the episode in a minute but first we
want to tell you about our sponsor fume
if you want to break break your bad
habit you can forget about having to go
cold turkey there's now a better way
we're talking about fume it's spelled Fu
M and pronounce fume which makes no
sense anyway not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a dramatic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that you can trade
breathing in nasty chemicals for
breathing in Fresh Air instead of vapor
fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses delicious flavors it's a habit
you're free to enjoy and makes replacing
your bad habit easy your fume comes with
an adjustable airflow dial and is
designed with movable parts and magnets
for fidgeting which gives your finger
something to do which is helpful for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your bad habit I'll be honest I wasn't
sure what to expect with fume but
they're actually more flavorful than I
thought and it actually feels fresh the
feel of them is nice it's well weighted
perfectly balanced and they're made from
real wood which feels nice and looks
great too fume has served over 150,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories there's no reason that can't be
you join fume in accelerating Humanity's
breakup from destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trif nume.com and use code trig to
save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's TR
f.com and use code trig t r to save an
additional 10% off your order today give
it a go it might just help you kick that
bad habit back to the
interview and this is a thing that I'm
worried about because I think it was a
few months ago when Elon and a few
people they signed a document requesting
that there's a moratorium on AI and as
Noble as that is and dis I would like
that the reality is that's simply not
realistic no it's going to well again
it's like a coordination problem um
because also like how do you you know
where do you draw the line technically
Google Maps is an ai ai is so broad as a
term so you need to like
they I think the purpose of that letter
was just to like raise attention um and
it did a good job definitely did a good
job um you know the type of Regulation
that I think makes the most sense in in
the interim while we're figuring this
out is like regulation on front what are
called Frontier models which are like
the just the leading most powerful ones
so like technically gbt 4 was a frontier
model 6 months ago whatever is currently
being worked on now that's the upgrade
to that is now a Frontier Model and the
thing is with these type of things where
like you know I I think it was pretty
irresponsible for open AI to go and just
release or or even like uh Microsoft and
they were using Bing they did that first
actually to there's no way they could
know what the down and we still don't
know what the downstream effects are of
having such a powerful language
manipulation tool released to the
internet released to billion people nine
you know 8 billion people um and to be
fair there is no way they can know until
they do it so like these companies are
going to be just running real-time
experiments on humanity and if it turns
out that these experiments actually have
a bunch of unintended consequences we
won't know until it's you know either
too late I'm not saying that like the
current models are a risk of Extinction
they're not but there's maybe like
Downstream second third order effects
again contributing to like not knowing
you know polluting the information
ecosystem this kind of stuff um that we
won't know until they've become so
integrated into the economy that they're
almost impossible to extract again
that's the thing our economy is getting
more and more integrated into AI or VI
sorry vice versa so some like one one
like sane thing that could be done is
like more regulation on Frontier models
because that will a that's sort of
making it's putting the responsibility
on the most powerful people within AI
the big the biggest companies so
minimizes the risk of regulatory capture
it's only really affecting the big boys
not the little the little guys can still
carry on developing um and those are
also the models that are most likely to
have like unseen risks and big big big
consequences but in terms of this like
wider question of
like AI ex like speeding up the
misalignment that's already inherent
within our sort of economic
system I don't know like it's just so
hard cuz it's like it's like it's like a
game of whack-a-mole but instead of like
20 little things it's like
20,000 and it's it's also from a
personal point of view more and more
I've just had the realization that the
the amount of time that I spend online
is also proportionate to
the
the the amount of misery that I feel
I've
realized as I get older that the more
the less time I spend online the happier
that I am CU life really is all about
connection it is that's why people love
podcasts because it's about people
connecting in a way that we rarely do
anymore sometimes because our lives are
so busy the only time in my day when I
actually get to sit and have a
conversation with another human being
for a prolonged period of time where my
phone is off is to do this wow and
that's fundamentally unnatural yeah
and I think more and more that in order
for us to be happier we need to kind of
just take a step back and have that
personal responsibility yeah and there's
like genuine wisdom in the saying go out
and touch grass yeah like truly everyone
laughs about it but like no people are
so disconnected not only from each other
physically just from the physical
physical reality dig the digital realm
is it is it is a universe of sorts but
it's not a universe that we evolved out
of yeah or and and it it almost feels to
me like it's like this this reality
that's growing stronger that's like
feeding off our Consciousness in some
way like in my video I did this thing
like cuz that's like how I feel
sometimes when I'm just like on my phone
and I'm sitting with my friends then I
remember like 15 years ago we'd be
sitting around and we'd be all like up
in each other's stuff you know talking
or whatever and now half the time like
these things are like like they're like
an appendage on our arm that is just
like a parasite sucking all of our
attention into and we're just like
they're feeding them as opposed to them
adding to us that's that's the thing
it's like how do we it feels like that's
the
trend would you not also agree that I I
think we we love to bang on about how
evil social media is but it's also
[__] great is [__] great how many
friendships do do we have all of us
because we're on social media how many
amazing people have we connected with
how many amazing things have we learned
how have we improved our understanding
of the world right and I think the same
thing is the case with with AI uh I'd be
curious to hear kind of what you think
are the biggest risks but also the
biggest rewards that will come from that
yeah so I mean there's there's like kind
of four different categories of risk
there's
the um the unintended consequences type
stuff so like you build such like an
incredibly powerful model that it you
know especially let's say it learns to
or you it doesn't even have to learn to
people are like already trying to build
models which can edit their own code and
like recursively learn so like that
opens up like a pretty obvious can of
worms at least to me you know it's like
now something can basically evolve
itself it's going to be doing it at a f
faster rate than any form of biology so
that's like the whole sort of like
darwinian type thing and it doesn't have
to turn evil and want to kill us it's
just like it might be so good and fast
at uh you know its goals might not be
perfectly aligned with ours and it would
therefore perhaps just use all the
resources that we need you know or our
environment is not suitable to its and
and it wouldn't intend to kill us it
just we would be a byproduct of whatever
it continues to do that's like one
category that's like the most like
classic um Extinction risk type thing um
and there lots of sci-fi when in my
youth about this which is a benevolent
AI realizes that the root of human
miseries humans and yeah I mean that's a
very like anthropomorphized version of
it I think like that's less plausible
than just the idea of like an unintended
consequence of like it's like it wants
more compute and the best way to get
more compute is to turn every little bit
of silicon it can finded into chips and
that we need we need that silicon for
other stuff you know um just you know
just biosphere changes that kind of
stuff that's that's like the extreme
sci-fi type thing but then there's the
more near-term things again like uh
speeding up the misalignment in the
system like basically bad not bad
companies but like companies that are
just wanting to do their thing
maximizing for profits or whatever and
now are made even faster and more
efficient at doing that at like you know
cutting down the rainforest or all these
things and then there's like the bad
actor problem MH so you know cuz like
one one argument people put out for like
open sourcing is like well if we open
source then we can get um more people to
like be thinking at how to build
incorporate safety we can Hive mine this
which seems nice in principle but the
trouble is if you completely open source
a a very powerful model um a model that
had been kept close or so you'd put all
these safety measures in well now any
bad guy and the thing is is that we do
have a 1% rate of psychopaths on this
planet and it only take even like a
percent of a percent of them you know if
they found a way to make these things
you know to truly cause the max damage
they could you know like think think
like Isis type mentality people
something like that now like how do you
protect against them you can't so
there's that sort of category of risk
and then you've got the fourth one which
is uh sort of structural type problems
that might come from like basically the
sudden shock of such a powerful new
technology becoming ubiquitous so like
mass unemployment is a classic one yes
um you know we're already starting to
see signs of it and I'm not convinced by
the arguments that
it will be able to create new jobs fast
enough to um fill in the gaps of all the
ones it's displacing like it doesn't
seem obvious to me that that would be
the case um so there's those kind of
risks too and this sorry sorry I just
wanted to finish on the benefits because
because you you know in your video you
talk about negativity bias right human
beings have we we prioritize negative
information and I said to you what are
the risks what are the benefits and you
like Risk risk risk risk risk let's move
on no you're absolutely right you're no
you're totally right and and and that's
the difficult thing because there are so
many problems that AI can help to solve
right you know like a lot of the
environmental issues we have because we
haven't figured out how to have like
more abundant clean source of energy AI
could help us figure out nuclear fusion
so we need it for that it could help us
do with drug Discovery so it you know
especially if like there are all these
new potential pandemics on the on the um
on the timeline because that's the thing
again theyi it's what you call a du use
technology dep not not all of the
different flavors of it are but certain
categories of AI tend to be dual use
they can be used for good or for bad
but I I kind of I'm like bipolar on the
topic almost because you know when I
spend a lot of time thinking about these
coordination issues you know like how do
we coordinate to for climate change or
whatever we almost need some kind of
super intelligence to help us better
coordinate on these things things in a
way that doesn't also then just lead us
like vulnerable to tyranny or
nightmarish like type top down scenarios
so you know the bull argument for like
going all in on AI as quickly as
possible is that we won't be able to
solve these other problems without it
but then it opens up new cans of worms
that might make these existing problems
or even brand new ones worse so it's
like it feels like it's like this mind
field we have to navigate to get through
but if we get through then it's like
yeah and it's also as well the reality
is is that there are people who I mean
we don't live in a unipolar world we
live in a multi-polar world and the
reality is is that if we don't invest in
AI China Russia will do so that's the
classic yeah the moock Trap you call it
exactly yeah so we right back into that
yeah but one thing that I really wanted
to talk to you about live moving on is
Um poker and in particular strategy
firstly how did you get into poker
because you studied astrop physics at
University and then you became a poker
player are those connected is it
mathematics uh no it was very very
random um I
graduated really didn't want to get a
real
job was trying to do anything I could
and I started applying for game shows in
the in in the UK and not what type of
game shows just any of them that would
accept me basically uh um I was on
Golden Balls oh really okay that type of
game show that one
um I I I I defected I stole uh yeah I
feel feel bad about that one um what
else uh codex with Tony Robinson don't
that was great um they locked you in the
British museum overnight and you had to
solve all these Clues um but anyway one
of the first shows in fact the first
show I got on was one that said could
you use your powers of skill and
deception to win
£100,000 that's a lot of money yes
please um so yeah and I got selected as
one of the five contestants and then
they did this big reveal that they were
actually going to teach us how to play
poker mhm and like the loose premise was
like which personality type is best
suited for the game and I was the
professor as they called me um and I
didn't win the show but I
just absolutely fell in love with with
the game um you know at the time I also
wanted I was really into metal music and
wanted to be a sort of be a rockar and I
was like oh wait this is probably easier
in many ways cuz I wasn't that good at
guitar um a a way to like I wanted to
travel the world basically and live a
very ridiculous life and poker seemed
like a fun way to do that wow okay so
how much of it is luck how much of it is
strategy in order to become a good poker
player so it depends on the time Horizon
you're talking about like if the three
of us sat and played for half an
hour it's basically all luck mhm
assuming you know roughly how to to play
um but if we played for a week I'm going
to win probably 98% of the time
something like that um I again I don't
know how good you guys are maybe one of
you very good no no I think I think you
underestimate that your success rate in
that scenario it be closer to 100% right
so so basically there's there's a lot of
luck and you know any given hand there's
a lot of luck and Randomness because the
deck deck is shuffled between each hand
Etc you can't control what cards you get
um but the more you play the more
decision points there are the more any
Edge that the better player has
accumulates and how much of it is about
reading people's uh emotional cues Tails
Etc how important is that um if you're
just some purely analytical nerd that
can't read people at all can you be a
successful poker player yeah so let's
put it this way the best poker player on
earth is the most analytical nerd you
could imagine because it's an AI it's an
AI that doesn't know human emotion it
doesn't read people in that way it's
just so good at calculating the like the
game theory basically the these Nash
equilibria um it's so good at that that
it is able to beat the very best humans
on Earth consistently if they were to
sit and click buttons against this thing
for Infinity this thing would crush them
so what that says is that the game
really at its core is a game of math wow
yeah um now that's not to say that there
isn't this like level of meta
information that you can use and what's
interesting is how the games changed
like when I first learned to play and
certainly like the decade before like in
the '90s um the best players in the
world were incredibly um they were like
these like old school Hustler type guys
you know like the classic in you know in
in the casino with the cigar um they
would make these sort of inspired
intuitive plays that they couldn't even
explain why they did them they just had
really strong gut feelings and that
their gut feelings were really like
really accurate at least more accurate
to everyone else so that's why they were
so good but as you know the game moved
into online poker more and we started
having like more data basically to
synthesize and analyze then we started
building software to analyze that data
the game became more and more of a
science and less of an art and sort of
trended towards this very mathematical
style now that's not to say
that good very you know the very best
players these days know how to do both
types they are very mathematical they
understand all the game theory but
they're also great like readers of human
behavior those are the very best players
um but
still technically they would lose to the
machine that's how good it is and how
useful is that ability to read other
people in poker to normal life like can
you tell what we're thinking now I I
can't tell what you're thinking like
what what you learn in poker and I think
this is true in almost anything any kind
of well there's the fly um what what
you're really looking for
is figuring out what someone's Baseline
behavior is when they are not like doing
the activity so they're not in a poker
hand or they're not in a negotiation fig
you know are they a naturally relaxed
person are they quite tense are they
extroverted introverted Etc and then you
want to see how they deviate from their
Baseline when you're actually in in play
so
some yeah some some people are naturally
like very intense when they're playing
and all of a sudden they become all Lang
languid and something that that that can
be sometimes some relevant information
but the trouble is as well is that fear
and excitement present themselves very
similarly so that's a real tricky one
when you're like so you know we're
playing and you go all in put me to the
test and I can see your heart is going
and and you're breathing fast and your
like your mouth is clearly dry that
could be excitement or fear so one
little thing I found helpful is
sometimes to like let just like make
someone sit there and sweat it for a few
minutes like pay attention to how they
are after 3 minutes or 2 minutes however
long I can stretch it out for because if
they are excited you know if they have a
good hand
typically the that excitement will wne
you know they've made their big action
and now they're just waiting to see what
you do and they they don't really
there's nothing more they have to worry
about so they'll typically calm down but
if someone is
bluffing the their heart's still going
after 2 minutes and they that's still
you know they're still very very
stressed so that can be one way of
discerning um but again like the main
thing is that there's no one size fits
all uh and you just have to be um it
it's something that you really
can't explain people just have to gather
through experience and I was going to
say Liv how does mathematics work with
poker you get given your
hand how do you then deern what the best
play is with your hand because obviously
you don't know the hands of other people
right so it's all
about this concept called like ranges
we're going to get quite specific here
so you know you're playing Texas holdom
yeah you get two cards out of a deck of
52 there's 1,326 possible combinations
of two cards that you could get I hope
those numbers are right it's been a long
time if they're not they're not I'm
pretty sure that's the number and so all
you know so to begin with you know I
have two cards out of a possible
combination of that that's one
combination out of 1326 so that's like
right now my range is 100% of
uncertainty to you but then let's say
you know I you raise and I now re ra
well now you can narrow down that range
because I'm probably not going to be re
raising with like let's say the bottom
40% of of those cards right um there
might be some and so on but over as the
hand progresses you will get your your
job is to try and extract as much
information out of me as you can while
at the same time giving as little to me
as possible because I'm trying to do the
same thing right so you're trying to
narrow down the range of cards your
opponent could conceivably have by you
know putting them to the test or seeing
how they behave um while keeping the
range of perceived cards that you have
as wide as possible so that's what
you're trying to do in in fundamental
you know fundamental terms and then
there's basically sort of mathematics
you can do within that let's
say I
bet um 100 into a PO of you know the
existing 100 so now you have to call 100
to win 200 so you're getting two to one
right and now you can see this stuff
called like basically pot ODS and then
like these combinator combinatorial um
calculations you can do to see if you're
getting the right kind of price um I
won't go into the Manu of that but
that's the kind of stuff so so there's a
real strategy behind it and the question
I think that is really relevant for
everybody watching this and particularly
people who who aren't interested in
poker
is has that helped you to strategize in
life and also what are the best poker
strategies that you can take for real
life that people can Implement um I
would like to think it has because like
one of the main things poker teachers
you to do is to just like be comfortable
with uncertainty be comfortable with
just seeing things probabilistically
which actually leans into kind of brings
us full circle back to the the this this
issue that we have with today's modern
media right we don't know what's quite
true you'll some you know oh they found
aliens you know the Mexican Congress are
being shown this this alien shape well
what's the likelihood that it's real
what's the likelihood it's not okay
that's maybe a silly example because
that was pretty obvious that it was not
real but you know some of these things
you truly can't know and you might never
find out what the truth is
and so you what poker teaches you is to
be like okay well I'm like I feel like
30% of the time they have this kind of
hand and then 40% of the time this and
then 30% of the time they have that or
whatever you know you're you're very
used to thinking about things
probabilistically and with this like
gray scale and that's the most useful
skill by far because um I mean even
things like
uh trying to take it right you know
decide whether to park illegally
somewhere not that I would Advocate that
but you know you're running late for a
meeting [__] I don't want to get a
parking ticket but I don't want to be
late for my meeting what I would do is
go okay well what's a probability I'll
get a ticket while I'm parked here okay
it's probably like I'm here for half an
hour it's probably only like 10% okay
how much is the ticket if I get it it's
$100 all right so that's expected
expected loss of $10 would I be willing
to pay $10 to park right now and be on
time for my meeting yes okay I'll park
you know that's the kind of thing these
these expected value calculations which
you don't learn in school and they're so
useful they're so important um so yeah
living living with just grayscale and
and probability is probably the number
one thing we'll be back with our guest
in a minute but first we want to take a
moment to talk about our partners give
and go if you need to raise funds online
but don't want to hand over your money
to faces big Tech corporations then give
send go is a place to do it giv and go
is a leading crowdfunding website where
thousands of people in the us the UK
Australia and Canada raise funds for
anything from business ventures and
medical expenses to personal needs
churches and funeral costs on give and
go you can raise money for whatever you
need we've met the people at giv and go
and we can tell you that they're
absolutely aligned with us here at
trigonometry on our approach to free
speech they've proved time and again
they won't C to the Mob they don't just
talk the talk they walk the walk unlike
other big tech companies and that's why
we are proud to partner with them they
like us believe that with openness and
honesty we create more understanding and
ultimately more Harmony in the world
give send go is absolutely free to use
with other crowdfunding sites you'll pay
between 5 and 10% of the money you raise
GI and go charges no money at all to use
their platform they believe you should
be able to keep all the money that you
raise starting a campaign on give sen go
is easy and intuitive go to giv send
go.com today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever is important
to you and now back to the
interview the next thing is like
learning how to like deal with luck and
Randomness because one of the hardest
things in life is like when you know
let's say we have a big success at
something is it because we did a really
good job you know we we we're just
better than everyone else or was it more
because we got lucky or some combination
of those two and again like poker it's
like I won very early on in my career
this huge tournament uh this European
Poker Tour Tournament and I after that
basically for a period of time for the
next six months because it was such a
big tournament I got so much attention
for winning it I just assumed I was
God's gift and I stopped studying The
Gamers hard I started playing in bigger
tournaments like riskier tournaments Etc
and my win rate just went like
absolutely plummeted to the floor and
that's because I got Fooled by
Randomness a little bit like I obviously
did a lot of stuff right to win that
tournament but I also had so much luck
on my side
and
our egos have a tendency or you know the
narrative we tell ourselves is we like
to take credit for our successes and
Outsource blame on luck you know I got I
just got unlucky when when things don't
go well and poker teaches you to
basically Al be like honest with
yourself you have to be epistemically
humble and and like really scrutinize
you know okay what you know what was the
cause of this was it because I was I did
things right or because I got lucky and
therefore it trains you to be more
focused on process as opposed to outcome
and result like if you develop a good
process that's kind of agnostic to
whether luck is on your side or not then
that's the Benchmark you should measure
yourself against so that's the other one
and then the third one is like don't
over privilege your intuition in situ
ation where it your intuition is not
best suited um
because again like the the natural thing
if I'm playing in a if I was playing
poker and and I couldn't you know my
brain wasn't working well and I couldn't
think through all these combinations and
so on is go well I'll just go with my
gut and after 15 years of playing my gut
was Fairly reliable but certainly for
the first 5 10 years of playing my gut
was not very good and so that would be
um I would often use my intuition as an
excuse to just not do the boring number
crunching and again people I I I've
noticed that's a a a trend that a lot
that seems to be widespread in the world
you know you look at these memes online
um if you search for like
intuition everything the internet says
oh trust your intuition 100% of the time
it's always right and it's like that's
just [__] you know after even 15
years of playing poker and thinking I
have great intuitions I would still have
an error rate I'd be so sure that
someone was bluffing me and then it turn
out that actually they had a really good
hand and but my gut was like screaming
no call call and it was wrong so that's
the other one be careful of like over
relying on on on intuition and Instinct
um in situations where really you just
need to do the like the the boring
number crunching and it's such a
powerful message because so many people
make decisions that are emotional not
based in rationality and then it turns
out that they're terrible decisions
because you're not making an objective
choice because you're let you're letting
your emotions
hijack your decision making process yeah
and and and the reason you know if
you're just doing stuff purely on
Instinct all the time you can't go in
and then scrutinize what your thought
process was at least if it's like you're
doing something like logically you can
like look back at it and go okay that's
probably where my bias and my emotion
clouded this bit but when it's like pure
intuition
stuff you got it's it's a black box you
don't know what's going on in there and
and they're still vulnerable to to
emotional bias and that kind of stuff so
yeah it's uh I don't know I wish I had
like a clean clean answer to like
how I'm curious is it possible to
control your own
tells um is that something poker players
work on you do
um I mean again like I should cave at
this I haven't I I quit poker like four
years ago you know properly now um I'm
not sure what the like latest strategies
people are doing
um you definitely like I would practice
it's not like I would sit in front of
the mirror or anything like that because
I would watch videos of myself like you
know if I played a final table I would
then go back and watch it afterwards if
it was televised to see oh okay so this
is how I was behaving there good to know
I'm gulping a lot and I'm clearly you
know when I was running a huge Bluff
um
but you know a good Poker Face is
basically something that's just it
doesn't have to be a dead pan it's just
something that is natural to you some
people are naturally very animated so
you just want to train yourself
basically it's through exposure therapy
of being in like these stressful high
stake situations the more you're in them
the the less you're going to have the
flight or fight response so that's
really the training you can do um you
know you
can't you can't train your poker face
but if you're like for a huge final
table until you've actually just been
there and done it and felt how it felt
and dealt with all the physiological
annoyances that your body throws at you
I remember the I remember the first time
I did question time
I was completely calm on my way there
the dry Francis came with me completely
calm when we got there completely calm
as we did the warm up complete and then
when it came to to the actual show I
suddenly couldn't move my body for like
5 minutes I could just do this and my
the rest of my body was just like
rigidly stuck in one place so but then
as the show went on I relaxed into it
but it's amazing how like it just flips
and it's not something that you truly
control second time you do it you
actually relaxed yeah um I I I uh I
still you know I do a lot of public
speaking these days and I still get like
incredible strage fight each time um I
did just for the first time try beta
blockers you know which are like they're
meant to help just like slow down the
heart rate and so on just like help with
the physiological symptoms and they did
actually really help so I kind of wish
I'd discovered these long ago when I was
playing poker um but yeah it's I don't
know so I I think some some people's
bodies there's a lot of variation
between people as well like exp you know
practice obviously helps but a big thing
I learned is just like I I I learn to
accept that I'm just always going to
have a high heart rate um when I'm
stressed and that's just how my body
responds um I having long hair would
actually help him poker I would do this
a lot to just try and hide it um but
yeah just it's kind of get comfortable
with the fact that you are going to be
stressed sometimes and there's just like
the worst thing you can do is beinged
about being stressed right so yeah it's
practicing acceptance I think that's the
most important thing when you are in a
situation and you feel stressed you go
okay why am I feeling stressed and most
of the time it's because you're
catastrophizing and actually once you
analyze it and you take a step back and
go this is just an emotion that's all it
is and think that's a really well
certainly with me that's a really good
way I found to deal with that that
realizing that you're not your emotions
you know
this is just a thing that is
temporary what's the biggest uh amount
of money you won in a tournament um it
was that you yeah it was 1.25 million
EUR it's incredible it's a good week it
a good week was 25 you were 25 and you
got thank God you weren't a 25y old
man I was much better what did you do
with it uh no I was actually pretty I
was pretty reasonable um I bought a flat
in London
um and then put a bunch of it back into
poker um as I said probably a bunch of
it into that six months after where I
wasn't playing very well did you think
like this is the beginning this is it
now I'm going to be winning like this
every few months or every week or I I
thought I was God's gift I mean so would
anyone really I mean to be fair to you
if I was 25 years old and I won a poker
tournament where I won €1.25 million
you'd be dead oh yeah and and before my
inevitable death I would be a raging
[__] yeah um I
mean I didn't do anything too nuts in
terms of lavish spending I mean I just
it was more just like what so so after
winning that the British press speaking
of tabloids got a hold of it daily mail
turned up at my parents house my mom
didn't know so she let them in they were
taking photos of my like childhood
pictures they on there now um yeah I was
on the front page of like a bunch of
tabloids that week because it was you
know there was some angle there I don't
know quite what their angle was I guess
it was just like I was a young cuti girl
who had an interesting story um and that
was I mean it was the highest high that
week talk about dopamine spikes my God
and then it like once it all sort of
settled down I think I probably had like
a big crash as well um and I remember
wanting that having that taste of Fame
that was definitely a thing that like
there was a part of my brain that wanted
to get back to it was like okay well I
need the next wind so I can keep that
going and then when it didn't come as
easily um that was interesting to adjust
to um and why did you
stop in the end combination of things um
a the game has gotten so much harder
really so much harder yeah well again so
AI big part of that um like online poker
is basically done for high stakes money
you can play low stakes or whatever and
that's fine but because you can now have
an A an AI that is playing effectively
in real time that's far better than
anyone else it's just there's incentive
for people to cheat and use them and so
there's
that then also the average player is
just so much better than they used to be
because all this like strategy
information has been very democratized
you know these tools are very easy for
anyone to work with now so the average
Joe is just much better at poker um and
then thirdly I just kind of got bored of
it as well I've been doing it for a long
time and felt you know various forms of
itchy feet also it's like you know the
ultimate Zero Sum game by definition and
I wanted I felt like I should probably
do something else than just that for the
rest of my life that's a little bit more
positive some bit more win-win and plus
you got a taste of the the sort of the
celebrity and now you make
content now I'm one of those
people um I try and justify it to myself
uh that I'm doing you know I really
really believe in the content that I'm
making let's put it that way yeah um I
that's a good reason to make content
explaining this these concepts of like
shitty Game Theory you know the the like
competition gone wrong in society and
like trying to think of like get more
people thinking about it to like
hopefully will then Hive minded solution
to this um definitely feels you know
like my my calling um hate that phrase
but uh why did you hear that phrase I
don't know it feels cuz you're British
cuz here everyone's like it's my mission
right I yeah and I'm so blessed I can
hear my M stop boasting stop bragging um
but no I really really believe in in in
finding ways to defeat mik and I think
this is my best way of doing that I'm
seem to be good at making these little
fil films about it and I've not to Pimp
My podcast too much I just launched this
podcast called win-win which is about
finding win-wins in seemingly win- lose
situations yeah and I'm so excited to
see the type of guess I saw the
announcement instantly retweeted it
because it's it's going to be great uh
on that happy note uh before we go to
locals where we ask you some of the
questions from our supporters uh the
last question we always end with is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
the one thing we are not talking about
enough
is whether you want to call it mollock
whether you want to call it coordination
problems uh multi-polar traps inadequate
equilibria whatever
word means the most to you the these
forces of um short-term incentives that
are not that are misaligned with what
the world actually needs and are
creating these race to the bottom
spirals within Industries or within
little sections um we aren't talking
about like The Meta level stuff you know
the actual fundamental structures of
these systems um sufficiently everyone's
just too busy pointing fingers going you
did that therefore you're bad and it's
like let's focus more on the you know
like basically don't hate the players
hate the game and how do we fix the
game that's what we're not talking about
enough libur thanks for coming on thank
you head on over to locals where we
continue the conversation with your
questions
why do you think women are so bad at
poker I mean I think it's a joke but
serious question women do underperform
in every available metric I'd like to
know what you think are mix of factors
are responsible for
[Music]
this